[Music]
oh
he
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowflakes heads explode let
me be clear before this podcast begins
we are loud loud proud proud and do not
give a
[Music]
[__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony
Michaels hey Tony [__]
[Music]
them
the Republicans are in disarray actually
you know what that's
offensive that's offensive to the word
disarray oh my God in the senate in the
house uh in up in New York in a
courtroom you couldn't get any better
you couldn't get any better than
this what a what a great day what a
great day in American politics oh man
just fantastic the new the new wiener of
the house believes that the CBO
score he says he says only in
Washington where we cut spending does it
increase the deficit yeah what a [__]
idiot yeah when you when you make sure
that a bunch of billionaire tax cheats
don't have to pay their taxes to I don't
know the Internal Revenue Service like
the department where they collect
[__] money yeah you're not going to
collect as much [__] money dum dum
which is gonna add to the what do they
call that what what do they call what do
they call that oh yeah the
deficit what a bunch of [__]
boneheads and then they're fighting in
the Senate that's right they're fighting
in the Senate even Lindsey Graham
understands how much of a [__]
bonehead Tommy tuberville
is yesterday they were trying to get
they're trying to get one by one
nominations and now tville is stopping
the one by one nominations which is
fantastic keep going Marjorie Taylor
green is beefing with chip Roy in the
house she's like yeah January 6 was an
Insurrection I mean that's basically
what she's saying because she's saying
Pro Palestinian protest were an
Insurrection
and she's saying well you call January 6
Insurrection so this is Insurrection so
you're admitting then Marjorie Taylor
green that January 6 was a Insurrection
oh
that's talk about [__] running into
the truth full speed oh my God these
people never stop but you shouldn't want
them to put down their shovel yet not
yet hell no when they're digging their
political grave order a backo for these
dumb sons of
[__] honestly I mean what what better
image do we need going into the general
election next year not just not just the
presidential election that one's going
to be [__] easy as long as we do our
jobs we're going to slam dunk that son
of a [__] aren't we
godamn but we got the Senate we got the
house to contend with we got State
governorships we got state state houses
and state senates that we got to win
back we got to make some Headway here
and you know what when the Republicans
are just standing there digging their
political grave we should not stop them
we should let them keep going this is
what they want to do folks they want
authoritarianism they want fascist M
show the [__] world what what it is
that these [__] idiots want just do
it just show it to them stop [__]
codling them and protecting them from
the world seeing who they really are let
them [__] see it Tommy tuberville is
a piece of [__] trash and Alabama
should be goddamn ashamed of themselves
that that guy is represents them at all
not even just as a United States Senator
at
all they should act like he never
coached aotb football team in anywhere
in [__] Alabama by the way the guy
didn't even live in [__] Alabama did
you know that he lives in [__]
Florida or some [__] kind like Josh
Holly in
Missouri which I showed the video
yesterday of Josh Holly just after
getting getting ripped to shreds by
secretor secretary my orcus and he went
and bragged about it talking about how
he he
torched my orcus who in the hearing
explained to Josh charie that his mother
was a holocaust Survivor and all of her
relatives were cooked in
ovens by the
Nazis and Josh Holly is out bragging
about it on social media in Fox News
[__] that piece of [__] what a [__]
prick what a goddamn little [__] Josh
Holly is and I can't wait until we we
can I don't know maybe show
some H some footage of him getting
caught by his wife watching a certain
type of porn just saying you know the
kind that Josh Holly thinks doesn't make
you manly you know what I'm talking
about but the all these are wedges all
these are political wedges and it's the
reason why their party is absolute trash
and [__] and it's
dead they can't even manage they can't
even manage to cut off the the cancerous
[__] sludge that is the Trump family
these people are going to have to
testify in open court yesterday Donald
Trump Jr I guess he couldn't recall I
can't recall I don't know anything about
accounting I just signed things I had no
idea what I was doing these people claim
to be really smart [__] business
people and so intelligent and oh my God
they're so great at this and all this
[__] but he can't even [__] recall
what business decisions he was making
come on man are we really supposed to
believe this [__] and Eric Trump's
supposed to get get up on the stand
today I
guess boy you talking about a lot of
[__]
guming in the courtroom today we're GNA
see a lot of gums in the courtroom today
I guess I got a little bit of footage
and some photos from the courtroom so
we're going to go into that oh yeah by
the way remember how they were so the
Republicans I showed you uh last Friday
on bone end of the week because George
Santos made the bone of the week because
the Republicans were going to expel him
remember
that H they
[Laughter]
didn't oh my God you need a two-thirds
vote um in the
house to expel someone two-thirds is
what you need to expel
someone I mean it's kind of difficult
for the body of the House of
Representatives to expel one of their
members because you got to get a
consensus you know it's got to be 2/3
but they couldn't even get a simple
majority they need Jordan Santos they
need that line son of a [__] they need
that crooked [__] they need him
I mean goddamn he's one of the best
Republicans they got if you think about
it really I mean he's one of the best
they got he's one of the best goddamn
Liars shamelessly doesn't give a [__]
and he steals money from his
constituents and his donors godamn he's
like the best Republican that there
is he's one of the greatest at the game
really actually they should put him in
the Republican Hall of Fame if you think
about it George Santos is
like the best of the best of the
Republicans I mean as far as you know
their criteria matters grifting stealing
their [__] constituents money lying
to
people that's all that's all on brand
for [__]
Republicans and and and he wears he
wears weird ass fleeces underneath his
suit coats there's all kinds of [__]
weird points that George Santos Gets In
the Hall of Fame of the
gqp of the am real America First Nazi
party like he gets all kinds of
points he should be he should definitely
be on the Hall of Fame ballot for the
Republican party hall of fame I'm just
saying what do you want from me I told
you I told you months and months and
months ago when everyone was calling for
George Santos to resign I was like hell
to the no why do you want George Santos
to resign this is going to be [__]
fantastic to watch these idiots flare
around while they try to explain to us
why they want to keep George Santos
guess what I was
correct who gives a [__] George Santos
is out next year anyways that district
is gonna [__] dunk him in the trash
he won't even be the Republican nominee
he'll get primary and he'll be gone who
gives a [__] if he ain't jail by then
and [__] criminal stealing stealing
his his constituent credit card numbers
and backing up personal bills that's
some wild [__] right but I mean is it
really is it I mean if they're going to
expel if they're gonna expel George
Santos for doing that kind of [__] to
his to his donors and his constituents
why then why would they support Donald
Trump it's kind of like chip Roy going
hey Marjorie Taylor green you can't call
the pro Palestinian protest and
Insurrection because then they're
correct about the January 6 Insurrection
that it is an Insurrection you can't
can't say that [__] out out loud that's
why they're in a beef the petti yeti the
house
Squatch on this
morning the wiener of the house he has
no clue what he walked into does he oh
what a [__] idiot Mike Johnson mikro
Johnson little wiener he is he's got
little wiener energy too that guy oh
[__] I couldn't be happier that they
picked this [__] oh he is such a
dumb son of a
[__] he clear he clearly does not know
how the house how the house
Works he clearly is not he is not fit to
[__]
lead he's already in trouble when he's
being accosted in the hallway talking
about how the CBO scored his spending
cuts and he doesn't understand how that
adds to the
deficit bravo bravo Republicans you pick
the perfect guy the perfect guy the
perfect guy for the to represent
Republicans you fascist white Christian
nationalist piece of [__] it's perfect
why why wouldn't they pick someone who
would represent them truly you know
their stupidity they're dumb [__] I
mean this guy only thinks the Earth is
like 6,000 years old or some
[__] believes that we should set laws by
the Bible
right this is their guy
this is who they want he wants to ban
all women's health
care I'm sure he's I'm sure he's best
buddies with Tommy
tuberville not wanting the military at
all I know I know I know he doesn't want
the IRS looking into his Rich donors I
wonder if um Harlin Hitler has made a
phone call to the new wiener of the
house what do you think you think harlon
Hitler the guy who's got the sign mine c
um copy in his home in Texas the
billionaire you think he's already made
a couple phone calls he's like hey man
remember those remember those IRS agents
that are going to come after us rich
people why don't you try to get rid of
those [__] the [__] the Israeli funding
I mean if you gotta you know get people
to vote for it for that yeah sure
whatever I mean the guy who wrote the
book that I like to brag about he
[__] hated Jewish people oh man you
should read that book that he wrote
godamn I mean he said a lot of lot of
peric things
and he lied a lot he demonized Jewish
people a lot in that book but you know
if you got to tie the funding to the to
the Israeli aid for them oh man if you
could get us a sweet deal to make sure
that we don't have to pay the taxes that
we owe that would be
magnificent and that's what that's what
the [__] wiener of the house is
doing apparently they're going to bring
a bill to the floor I think democrats
should [__] vote no [__] you [__] you
that's what they should say [__] you
yeah I know it's a difficult position
for a lot of members that in Congress
that are Jewish but [__] that
[__] what the
extortion are you kidding me we're we're
gonna we're gonna play this extortion
measure with [__] billionaire the
money that billionaires owe already
folks they owe the [__]
money the only thing that the funding
does that Mike Johnson wants to cut is
pay for the IRS to go get the [__]
money it cost money to go deal with
these rich son of a [__] all say do
is hire rooms full of lawyers [__]
tie you up in court and cost you
hundreds of thousands of dollars
millions of dollars as a matter of fact
but it's worth it because they owe
hundreds of millions of dollars in taxes
that they're not paying that they owe so
[__] them go yeah that's worth
it I think all all the Democratic
members in the house should vote no [__]
them [__] them I don't give a [__] what
your religion what your background you
don't need to be extorted holding a gun
to your head so that billionaires can
cheat on their [__] taxes [__] you
and the American people get [__] on oh
my God it's the same [__] that
are complaining about the UAW deal that
they made with the big three oh man they
really screwed over those big
corporations didn't they
the workers they're so [__] greedy
really I don't see the I don't see the
UAW forcing the [__] speaker of the
house to make sure their benefits are
tied to Israeli funding do
you what a bunch of [__] scumbags as
if we got any other reason to hate
[__] rich people in this country
anymore God damn actually you know what
as a matter of fact let's just tax them
into Oblivion so they're not rich
anymore then we don't have to [__]
hate him as much it's
ridiculous yeah that's right I use the
word hate I mean man it's it's going
around it's a tough [__] situation
when you got to describe how you feel
about these these
cockroaches calling calling UAW labor
labor union members the people who work
on the [__] Factory
line who actually do [__] manual
labor demonizing them but then the
speaker of the house is going to protect
billionaires a bunch of [__] tax
cheats who owe money to us the
government us it's us [__] they
owe us money it's our [__] money not
theirs it's our [__] money we H we
hired our representatives to go to
Washington to make the [__] rules and
the laws one of them is the tax code we
did that we sent them there and they're
trying to cheat on the tax code so that
they keep our [__]
money it's ours they get to use our
[__] infrastructure they get to use
this [__] country we we spend
gazillions of [__] dollars on DOD to
protect those [__] business
interest all around the [__] world
and the best we get the best we get is
oh well that UAW deal boy it's a bunch
of [__] oh hey by the way get us
those [__] get us those [__] tax
cheats we want to be able to cheat on
our taxes Mike
Johnson it's literally what's going
on and mangas got their head so far up
their [__]
ass they think it's the opposite oh
Trump's oh Trump's he's he's such a
victim oh my God I can't believe how how
how they treat him get the [__] out of
here he wouldn't [__] spit on you if
you were burning
alive you dumb son of a [__] I had some
[__] on Twitter
coming coming my comments talking about
how I don't know rule America he says
I'm from Carney Missouri let me give you
let me give you an idea about where I'm
from I'm from the [__] Ozark
Mountains that the northern Ozark
Mountains near link of the Ozarks right
that's why I sound the how I sound and
oh by the way it's Halloween people
don't like how I say Halloween
apparently well I don't give a [__] you
know where the door that if you don't
like how I talk I don't give a [__] not
one not two [__] not even
one but he was talking about how I was
from the inbred part of Missouri and
that may be true I'm not gonna lie I'm
not gonna lie that W baby there's some
towns where I'm from some of those small
towns that H there might be a little
inbreeding but he's from Carney Missouri
he claimed he's from real Missouri and
he likes Trump he's from Carney
which is 10,000 people now to some of
you 10,000 people you're like that's a
small town Tony it's and trust me it's
not a small town that's not a [__]
small town okay I'm from a place that
would be considered a small town but
it's really not even that small of a
town there's almost 5,000 people there
half of what is in Carney and Carney is
a [__] is in Kansas City just on the
outskirts of Kansas City he's like
[__] half an hour away from the city
and this motherfucker's going to lecture
me on rule Missouri get the [__] out of
here
man listen I I I know I grew up there I
is one okay [__]
bonehead but that's how these people are
they can't pluck their heads out of
their asses and they
won't because they can't be wrong right
that's the one thing that the fash can't
do these white Christian nationalists
that's why they're so dug in right their
heels are dug in it's affiliate we
talked about it before but it's more
deep-seated than just the affiliation to
the Republican party it's more the
affiliation to their lies right you know
what I mean you catch my drift you smell
what I'm stepping in right you've met
these [__] you talk to them you
know that they know they're wrong you
know that they know they're full of [__]
right but they can't admit it because if
they admitted they were wrong about
Trump they have to be wrong about
everything else right because he allowed
them to be the worst version of
themselves that's what they love about
him
most it isn't that he's smart as's a
great business person that's all bunch
of [__] everyone knows that guy's a
[__]
buffoon and when he handed over his
business to his [__] son Don Jr a
trustee of his business and Don Jr has
to say I don't recall I don't recall I
don't recall I don't make financial
decisions with on the business that I'm
the the trustee of as if we're supposed
to believe that [__] so it's either one
or the other they're either line sacks
of [__] or they don't know business [__]
from Shinola really and that's probably
the case that they really don't know
[__] from
Shinola that they were always run by
corrupt [__] and they they
encourag the corruption they encouraged
the fraud they encourage the line that's
the [__] truth but manga can't see
that manga doesn't want to see that
that's why you have margorie Taylor
green and and Chip Roy beefing in the
house that's why you have speaker Mike
Johnson who doesn't even though the
world is a little older than a couple
thousand
years yeah have people in in the Senate
like Lindsey Graham that [__] scumbag
lady G scumbag on Tommy tuberville just
coming to the re realization that what
Tommy tuberville is doing is really
[__] despicable and vile and it
really doesn't look like he supports the
military and Veterans
or anyone America's safety at
all huh I wonder who's paying Tommy
tuberville by the way speaking of that
who do you think's paying that
[__] who do you think it is I
don't know someone's got to be paying
him right Tommy tuberville is not smart
enough to stand on any principle have
you ever heard him
talk have you ever heard him talk about
this
[__] this guy's a [__] idiot I can't
even believe I can't even believe they
considered him a good football
coach that's how ridiculous this guy is
how he moved up in the ranks in football
I have no idea and I don't really know
much about Tommy tuberville's football
career but if he did play football he
got hit a few few too many times on the
old [__]
coronium Skull Crushers right but even
lindsy Graham can't stand the son of a
[__] in what he's doing because he
knows it's violent
despicable I hell even Mitch McConnell
knows that these [__] abandoning
Ukraine the Democracy of Ukraine only
giving
Putin more more grasp on autocracy in
the world and smashing democracy even
Mitch McConnell even glitchy Mitchy
knows that that's [__] detrimental
not just to our democracy but
democracies all around the world which
hurts us in the long run
when you're undermining the idea that
democracy is
good [__] they got these [__] idiots
brainwash I'm gonna get a 100 comments
for the shorts on this video just today
this isn't a democracy it's a republic
that kind of
[__] but on it goes so don't take the
[__] shovel out of their hands and
really honestly let's encourage them to
get a
backo maybe get a d8 you know what I
mean really [__] dig that grave for
the Republican party I mean that son of
a [__] is dead we just need to get it
buried it's about goddamn time we bury
it and you know they're doing a
fantastic bang-up job of doing it
themselves just like you're doing a bang
up job of coming here every single
weekday oh my gosh you guys are here
every single weekday Monday through
Friday no Eastern 11 Central 9th Pacific
YouTube Facebook and twitch and let me
tell you something I want to uh give an
announcement here uh the first orders
for this machine kills fash is the
tattoo merch design the tattoo merch
collection the Tony Michaels collection
those first orders are being shipped so
all of you that ordered some of the
merch out there you can go to the Tony
michaels.com if you want to
catch the dis machine kills fascist the
tattoo merch collection that's right I'm
going to get this microphone tattooed on
my arm and that phrase tattooed on my
arm and it'll it'll be inspired by this
design I think we're going to spread
this design throughout the uh the Tony
Michaels universe but all your merch is
on the way even some of those U even my
dog hates take Cruise shirts and hoodies
are on their way I know a lot of people
have ordered those so if you ordered
it's on the way speaking of on the way
we're on the way to getting a book club
started over on Discord it's free to
join you just go to the Tony
michaels.com that's right you go to the
Tony michael.com you can read the
obstacle is the way by Ryan holiday and
get in on the book club they're also
going to be listening to Rachel mat's
audio book and having conversations
about that so they're not just going to
be reading books they're going to be
listening to audio which is kind of cool
there'll be streaming audio and there
you guys can listen and have discussions
um in Discord so make sure to go to the
Tony michaels.com let me show you where
to go here so you just go to the Tony
michaels.com hit subscribe at the top of
the page pan on down here's your merch
you get the tattoo merch merch here you
can get the my dog hates Ted merch here
then you pan on down two memberships you
can see the book club is right here
right here the third one in the
memberships column um you can also join
patreon for free now I want to thank
everyone there's been uh I think almost
150 of you go and join patreon for free
now you you only get access to a few
things if you join for free but you can
follow me over there I'll put any news
over there um I I've been posting the
articles that we generate with I Tony or
AI Tony uh over there on patreon I've
been usually doing one or two a day I
want to get to where I'm doing multiple
a day we just have to get the you know
kind of the the groove down and we we'll
be posting more and more articles on
more and more news stories over there uh
being generated with iony so it it seems
as if I'm writing them but it's actually
the the machine the machine just a love
machine HH it don't work for nobody but
you you like that you like the love
machine the love machine so go join go
go look at the love machine over there
on patreon it's free to join and I made
those articles for free because I kind
of asked people if we should make those
articles available to everyone and they
said yes resoundingly um so the patreon
members really wanted all of you to have
access to those articles uh and not cost
you anything now you can join as a
member I don't want to discourage you if
you want to support the show monetarily
you can join as a member for patreon
come join us on Sunday rants um if you
want to join the $20 tier that gets you
into the producers corner on Discord
every Monday and Friday morning an hour
before the show so tomorrow morning
we'll be doing a producers Corner we
just kind of gather up an hour before
the show we kind of talk to each other
you guys can come up on stage you can
talk it's kind of like a it's kind of
like a Twitter space if you want to know
the honest truth if you've ever been in
one of those it's just telephone is all
it is we just kind of talk to each other
we throw we never know what we're going
to talk about it's not recorded or
anything like that it's just a
conversation that we're having before
the show we talk about all the news
stories that's out there we talk about
the week in general we talk about some
of the stories that they think are
important uh and they want to get my
opinion on certain things and sometimes
I'm looking for their opinion your
guys's opinion and you to come up on
stage and tell me what your opinion is
of certain things and people tell
stories in there and everything The
Producers corner is a it's a great place
to hang out on Monday and Friday morning
an hour before the show so again go to
the Tony michaels.com you can click here
just you can join patreon free for here
if you want to support the show
monetarily you can look at those tiers
also the book club is free to join you
will have to join the Discord and I know
some people out there don't like the
Discord but I'm telling you you're going
to love this book club thing even if you
don't like the the rest of the Discord
because there's a lot of stuff in
Discord we're building like a town over
there it's like a digital [__]
town there's all kinds of stuff in there
there's an arcade we're getting an
arcade going there's a book club now um
so there's all kinds of there's a lot of
information about voting I know Mighty
librarian put a thing in there where you
can get
notifications uh on Election election
information so you can actually go to
the Discord join the book club and get
notifications about the election about
elections so go again to the Tony
michaels.com click on the book club and
go go check out Rachel mano's audio book
discussion and and also uh you can check
out the obstacle is the way is the first
book They're going to read by Ryan
holiday in the book club sponsored by
the library of
democracy oh boy we got a lot of clips
to watch today a lot especially of
speaker the speaker micro Johnson the
wiener of the house so don't go anywhere
we'll be right back right after
this we'll be right back Mark 60 seconds
this is the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
fast are you numb and alone after
storming the capital have you been left
out in the cold after stealing Nancy
pel's mail do you feel exposed to a
government that doesn't share your
patriotic values if any of these
describe you then you're in luck hi I'm
Paul gosar and thanks to my new product
paron blanket I've got you covered paron
blanket specifically Works to make you
feel safe and cozy after your
involvement on January 6th and if you're
one of the other members of Congress who
also helped with the attempted coup hard
and blanket will protect you too Hardon
blanket is made of a sort of soft fleece
and a layer of sheep's wool and they're
100% made in the USA don't delay and get
your pardon blanket today for just
$99.99 actual pardon's not
guaranteed jumping back into it this is
the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show thanks for
sticking around through the break by we
got a lot of new stories to get to and
it all has to do with Republican hisory
almost every single one of them they
can't govern they can't manage to
testify in court without
incriminating I don't
recall I don't recall what my criminal
daddy told me to
do oh holy [__] these [__] people now
we got some uh images speaking of the
courtroom we got some images from the
courtroom so we're gonna we're going to
play those here real quick let's see
here is Eric Eric Trump outside the
courtroom this morning he look he's got
five
fingers that looks pretty [__] real
doesn't it I'm not gonna lie Is that
real or is that AI God damn rat these
are getting more and more
[Music]
real
is
now I know we keep harping on this AI
stuff and is it real or is it AI but
this is important because holy [__] this
stuff is going to come down um The
Pike oh by the way by the way I have a I
have some images from the house as well
um the house Squatch the petty Yeti the
yeti of the house uh she's getting ready
for battle with chip Roy and the
Republicans so here is here's margorie
Taylor green margorie hoofoot green the
Petty Yeti how
Squatch I don't know can you tell if
that's real or is that a that looks real
to me I'm not going to lie here's
another one that [__] looks real to
me that looks [__] real to
me doesn't it to you that looks exactly
like marre Taylor green on a good
day oh boy we're gonna have a lot of
images today I want to go to uh some of
the clips though here in the courtroom
here I think this was this is from this
morning now now Don Jr testified
yesterday but but he hasn't quite uh
finished I think he's supposed to
testify today and Eric Trump is supposed
to take the stand too here is Don here's
Donnie in court with people within the
Trump organization about the valuation
of properties or deals made but he never
knew those numbers were actually going
to be reflected on official documents so
that's what we expect testimony to pick
up getting into the more nitty-gritty of
financial documents with Don Jr now we
don't expect the defense to ask Don Jr
any questions do you like the zooming
watch the zooming it feels like the
cameraman's on coke too either that or
it's just like you know residual from
this guy like secondhand
Coke he's got a secondhand Coke Buzz
just from standing this close to Don Jr
I mean Alina Abba looks like she's a
little stoned too I'm not gonna lie I
don't know if they're doing Aderall or
cocaine before this but whoa [__] but
here what watch the zooming effect
documents with Don Jr now we don't
expect the defense to ask Junior any
questions so after that his brother who
was also in the courthouse but not in
Karen says they look so uncomfy yeah
they should be uncomfortable [__] those
[__] they should be
uncomfortable sons of [__] look at
him looks like he [__] his diaper or
something um let's keep let's keep going
see what else they say about booger suar
Jr here in the courtroom will then take
the stand and the questions might be
even more pointed uh to Eric Trump
because his name has actually been
invoked by a number of Witnesses in this
trial so far uh when it comes to the
valuation of properties uh particularly
in New York and the Trump's Golf Course
properties now uh Ty Ross points out
here oh habin Jr definitely had a few
bumps before this oh yeah they were
[__] oh bumps of everything too it
wasn't just one thing who God knows how
much drugs they did before they got in
this some [__] you know you know
they're you know they're coped out of
their minds now why is it important that
these two people within the Trump organ
look at that look at that at the very
end that
zoom
zoom look at
that
cocaine
[Music]
cocaine can I get a I don't know can I
get a video of
that
cocaine this [__] guy look at him
look at him dude he's he's he's had to
have aged 14 years in the last two
months either that or that is
cocaine I don't know he looks man he
looks like [__] doesn't
he godd
damn that's what go and broke will do to
you $250
million oh son [__] all right well
there's Don Jr in court let's see if we
can get some images of him in court here
see what we got oh here he is yeah here
he is on his Bender
oh he's so it's so funny when he doesn't
recall isn't it it's so funny when he
doesn't recall Don Jr because apparently
that's all he could do yesterday is he
couldn't recall I can't recall I can't
recall that we even have a business to
be quite honest with you I mean we go
around and we brag about this business
and how great this business is and I've
done interviews about how great this
business is but today sitting here in
court where we're going to be held
accountable I really can't
recall you remember Marjorie Taylor
green doing that [__]
you remember that I can't recall I can't
recall I can't recall I can't recall I
can't recall now this is a Civil Trial
um so the problem with him not recalling
or even taking the fifth because when
you don't recall you're
basically you're basically exercising
your Fifth Amendment right because
you're saying something to answer a
question without self-incriminating do
you know what I mean
right so this I don't recall [__] is
going to come back to bite them and the
reason why is because the judges already
this this is civil this is not criminal
there does not have to be Beyond A
Reasonable Doubt and honestly the judge
has already decided that yes it is fraud
you guys committed
fraud this is just a matter of like oh
how much and how much money is it going
to cost you so this do not recall [__]
is only to protect them from criminal
charges because you know when he's like
I don't recall I don't recall I don't
recall they don't recall the
crime
right they do not recall the crime is
what he doesn't recall here he thinks
it's really funny or he's just CED out
of his mind here's another picture I
know are these real or these AI you
decide I know it feels like these aren't
that great like these are like you're
like no Tony this is obviously AI yeah
it's obviously AI today like right now
in this moment but I'm telling you six
months from now two years from now
there'll be a video of Don Jr like the
one I showed you from the courtroom
that'll look [__] real and it won't
be uh here's um here's six-fingered Eric
gonna testify apparently Eric Trump is
gonna take the U gonna take the stand
today here's six-fingered Eric taking
the stand I don't know maybe has six
fingers these people are these people
are [__] you know cockroaches so it
wouldn't be surprising if they have an
extra an extra appendage
somewhere oh my God I I love the I love
that it even has the water bottle I
wonder if that's Trump water you
remember Trump ice remember that video
of Sylvester Stallone talking about
Trump ice oh [__] we gotta oh man we
gotta play that [__] hang on a second
now that we now that we're here yeah
we're gonna we're gonna do goofing on
Trump ice um Sylvester Sylvester
Stallone was on Billy Bush's show uh one
time and Billy Bush was trying to get
him let's see I think it's on my
Instagram maybe um Billy Bush was trying
to get him to try Waters and tell him
which water was which you know like oh
this is this is danani and this is a you
know whatever brand of water and there's
one in particular that Sylvester
Stallone uh he drinks out of and it's
hilarious because it's his reaction
let me let me find that I I know it
feels like that doesn't matter but it's
funny and it's hilarious and I like to
goof on these son of a [__] so we're
gonna go play this video of Sylvester
Stallone tasting water that's what we're
gonna do if I can find
it yeah it's G to take me a minute but
we're gonna do it uh because we properly
goof here on the Tony Michaels podcast
that's how we do this
maybe oh it's such a good video so
the the thing is with this trial in New
York as Eric and Don Jr uh testify
they're actually on the hook for this
right it's because they were trustees in
this business and really honestly a lot
of the [__] blame is being is being
dumped on Eric and that's one reason why
is because he's a dumb Dum right it's
easy to dump dump that sort of [__] on
the dumb Dum because Eric
I mean you know Don Jr's stupid and
ianka pretends to be smart and I'd say
pretends on
purpose but Eric really truly is dumb as
dog [__] and he was willing to take the
heat for these idiots and that's the you
know the moral of the story here is that
not only has Donald Trump duped his
entire
cult he duped Banks he duped accounting
firms to do his bidding here he did all
this [__] all this [__] he did and he
even duped his [__] family to where
his family has to sit and his family has
to his is f is this oh yeah here it is
uh thank thank you thank you thank you
rat rat's got rat's rat's doing a great
job here at the show thank you R he he
found the Sylvester Stallone say from me
for me this is great this is great this
is from 2007 folks that's how long ago
this was now remember so put it in that
context this is from
2007 okay let's let's show here what rat
found here on on the interwebs just
listen that's the better water are you
serious and guess who the other water is
whatever it is I wouldn't wash my socks
in
this now I can't wait to tell you what
it is what Trump
ice I'm sorry
Donald I didn't know I love Donald I'm
sorry Sylvester loves Donald you want to
watch it again I want to watch it three
times so again this is Billy Bush right
here this is the guy this is the [__]
grabbing guy on the on the bus if you're
not familiar this is Access Hollywood
right this is when Trump was part of
Access Hollywood and they love to sell
that [__] idiot on Access Hollywood
right that this is Billy Bush he's the
one that was on the on the bus with
Trump when he was talking about grabbing
grabbing women by oh they just they let
you do it grab women by the [__] they
let you do it you remember that you
remember the [__] grabing video Billy
Bush was the one that was on he lost his
job at Access Hollywood over that tape
Donald Trump became the president of the
United States Billy Bush lost his
[__]
job but this is this is Billy Bush here
doing an interview with Sylvester
Stallone Sly as they call him Rocky and
they're testing Waters and Sly is
testing Waters here so catch he's he's
trying to guess which water is which but
listen to what he says about the one
water listen what real close that's the
better water are you serious and guess
who the other water is whatever it is I
wouldn't watch my socks in
this whatever it is I wouldn't wash my
socks in this now this is before he
knows um what the water is and watch his
reaction now I can't wait to tell you
what it is what Trump
ice I'm
Sor this video never gets old it never
gets old it never gets old because this
is Trump the story of his life this is
the 100% the story of his [__] life
is that he can't he can't even make he
can't even make a water he can't even
white label a water worth a [__] you
know what I mean cuz that's what he does
now thank you thankk you rant for the um
thank you for the for the clip um it's
really truly what he does is he white
labels all this [__] like the water that
he has the Trump ice he didn't actually
open up a [__] bottling Factory or
some [__] he went to a company and said
hey you make water will you slap my
label on it and they're like yeah like
what kind of water you want he's like
the shittiest water you can get I want
it to be the cheapest [__] garbage
that you can get put it in a nice bottle
put a nice label on it and I'll sell
that [__] as if it's
gold and it's the truth because
Sylvester Stallone's like I wouldn't
even wash my socks and I can't even
believe I took a drink of that
[__] I wouldn't even wash my socks in it
is what is what Sylvester Stallone says
before he knew that it was Trump now if
he knew it was Trump water he'd have
been he oh you would have [__] a you
would have been so foolish be like this
is the greatest water I've ever had in
my life because remember this is 2007
when Trump was the darling of Access
Hollywood you know when he was on NBC's
The
Apprentice when NBC proed that stupid
son of a [__] up and put it in the
minds of people the delusional idea that
somehow he's a good business person even
when they were showing on Access
Hollywood that he couldn't even white
label a water worth of [__] I bet the
guy never even took a sip of that water
before he slapped his [__] name on
he just said give me the cheapest [__]
you got I don't even give a [__] if it's
out of the
sewer just put it in a trump bottle and
I'll sell it as
gold and that's the entirety of the of
trump and that's what's going on in the
courtroom in New York it's the same [__]
they they got the the the bottom of the
barrel they scraped up the [__]
sludge and they sold it as [__] gold
and they defrauded people by selling
their sludges
gold and that's why he's in a [__]
New York courtroom that's why he's he
keeps bitching on true social leave my
children alone leave your children alone
you left your children in charge of the
[__] business you dumb [__]
they're adults they're F these aren't
[__] nine-year olds these are goddamn
adults and frankly these are the [__]
adult children that were on The
Apprentice with him where he was selling
them great business people too as if
there's some sort of Heritage in great
business I mean there's Heritage in
fraudulent businesses his dad was a
goddamn fraud Fred Trump was a [__]
fraud he took our money our taxpayer
dollars and built HUD housing and then
he took our [__] taxpayer dollars
from the renters that he put in the HUD
housing and he wouldn't let black people
in his goddamn HUD housing he
discriminated against them there's
Federal cases against Fred Trump and
Donald Trump
they've been doing this for [__]
decades and decades and decades this
isn't [__] new that's why this clip
is so hilarious that even even Sylvester
Stallone tasting the water knows the
[__] truth before he knows the
truth that all Trump does is scrape up
toxic [__] sludge and sells it as go
slaps his [__] name on it as if that
means anything anymore and then tries to
sell it as something
Elite and it's really funny that a bunch
of Toothless [__] rednecks out there
a bunch of brainless sheep believe that
somehow he's one of them these
[__] are always talking about
how Elite they are Jesus Christ Donald
Trump stands outside that courtroom and
[__] and moans and [__] complains
about how his [__] mansion in South
Florida on a golf course is it being
appraised high enough that it's worth
gazillions of
dollars and he's not an
elite he's a blue collar billionaire
what the [__] does that mean this guy
not only not only has he been taking the
state of New York's money he's been
shutting down mom and pop businesses in
the state of New York for decades and
decades doing the same [__] selling them
toxic sludge and making it making it
seem like it's Trump ice you know
branding into something great and
putting them out of I bet I bet the
water bottling plant that that [__]
bottle Trump ice is out of business
because of trump because they did
[__] business with that idiot and
bottled his toxic sludge and labeled it
Trump ice it's always the same old story
with this [__] every every single
[__] time it's never different never
and again the F the [__] brainless
sheep out there the manga sheep they
can't admit they're wrong if they admit
their wrong about Trump they have to be
wrong about everything that's how they
feel you know what I mean like that's
that's their personality now their fous
personality has been come become
embodied by Trump and manga and their
Worship in him and their membership into
the cult so if they admit he's wrong
they have to admit their entire
worldview is wrong because it is their
entire worldview is [__] they know it we
know it they just can't admit
it that's why you have in the house this
Skirmish between Marjorie Taylor green
and Chip Roy well and others but have
you seen this holy
[__] she she even went after Lauren
bobbert oh this is great you know I
think we pick out really good [__]
nicknames here here on the Tony Michaels
podcast one of them for Marjorie Taylor
green came from the chat the petty Yeti
um it is the inspiration for the yeti of
the house if you if you want to know the
truth this is where the petty Yeti comes
from here here She is uh in the House of
Representatives here here's a picture of
Marjorie Tor Green live the petty Yeti
the the house Squatch there um but again
this morning or yesterday actually I
should say but this morning there's a
little bit more
you know to this story because Marjorie
Taylor green now came up in the press
conference with the new wiener of the
house and he was asked about this little
Skirmish here but chip Roy press office
I love this I love how how these these
Republicans and any politician really if
you want to say it I'm good with that
because they have official
representative accounts you see this
this is rep chip Roy this is his
official account as a congress person
that's what the gray check mark is about
on TW on on xchan here I think that's
what I'm going to start calling it xchan
is great it's Twitter or it's xchan one
or the other um but chip Roy's
official Congressional account here it's
not representative chip Roy you see it's
press office that way if something gets
tweeted out in this thing wrong he can
just blame it on his staff he doesn't
have to blame it on himself he doesn't
have to be held accountable they don't
want to be held accountable for anything
anyways but here's chip Roy talking
about the the centure motion that
margerie Taylor green brought to the
floor and it was
tabled H they can't it's so funny it's
so funny Republicans can't govern like
literally they can't expel one of their
criminal [__] uh colleagues George
Santos and they can't they can't centure
a representative TB uh for her pro pro
Palestinian which appears in some
instances to be pramas I'm not going to
lie TB has gone way over the line with
some of this stuff now rather she should
be censored in Congress you know that's
up for Congress to decide the problem is
they decided that she shouldn't and the
reason why is because Marjorie Taylor
Green in her language of the of the
motion called her an insurrectionist and
they were like sh xay on the
Insurrection a like what are you doing
why are you saying this Insurrection
stuff out loud even chip Roy understands
that you can't say this type of [__] in
the way that marer Taylor green saying
it I showed you a video during the pro
Palestinian protest I believe it was
last week where Margie Taylor green is
standing out on the
capitol on on the on the steps and she's
saying this is an interraction this is
an inter and it's a protest not an
Insurrection they weren't trying to stop
official proceeding to overturn the
government they were just protesting to
the government but you know
[__] boneheads um but here here is um
here's here's chip Roy's tweet says
representa Le has repeatedly made
outrageous remarks towards Israel and
Jewish people her conduct is Unbecoming
of a member of Congress and certainly
worthy of comination if not censure um
he goes on however tonight's feckless
resolution to censure TB was deeply
flawed see he's not opposed to getting
rid of her he's not opposed to [__]
silencing her freedom of speech spech
right this is from the freedom of speech
people I don't actually think she should
be censored I think some of the stuff
she's saying is not not good for her to
say but I don't actually think that it
matters uh to her seat of Congress if
you want to know the honest truth that's
that's the thing again I don't agree
with some of the [__] she's saying I
don't agree with some of that [__] but
that's not again she's not going to
agree with [__] I say you see what I
mean you see what I mean like you know
Liberty and [__] and I actually do not I
I actually do not think that that that
it affects her congressional seat in in
that way I really don't um because
they're trying to paint her up as some
sort of terrorist terrorist sympathizer
and I don't think that's actually what
she's doing um but you know talib's
gonna do what she thinks is best and if
she can't get her reelected because she
says that [__] well that's just how the
cookie crumbles uh but Chi Roy goes on
he says I voted to table the
resolution oh these [__] scum EGS in
January 20 here we go listen to this
because Marjorie Taylor green TR made
this a January 6th issue right now she
just didn't want to censure what Talib
had said out loud she wanted to censor
her because she had participated with
the protesters at which again I I
believe that member members of Congress
should be able to protest as as members
of Congress and I think they should be
able to Pro peacefully protest as
members of Congress who aren't acting as
official members of Congress they're
acting as American citizens so you know
and there's a gray area there right and
that's what you have to determine on
motions on the floor of the house but
chip Roy is really pissed off that
margorie Taylor green invoked the
January 6 insurrectionist and the reason
why is because when margorie Taylor
green calls a pro Palestinian protest a
peaceful Pro Palestinian protest that
doesn't result in violence or I don't
know trying to overthrow our [__]
Constitution [__] bonehead when you
point out that that's an Insurrection
right when you say that's an
Insurrection and you're passing a motion
on the floor and they're voting for a
motion on the floor to call it an
Insurrection
because January 6 was an Insurrection
you're admitting margerie margerie M
Marge March listen listen really clear
if you're going to
say that the pro Palestinian protest are
an Insurrection like the January 6
Insurrection is Insurrection you're
admitting that January 6 was an
Insurrection how the [__] don't they
know this [__] I mean chip Roy knows it
he says I voted to table the resolution
in January 2021 the legal term
Insurrection was stretched and abused
because he is an insurrectionist I don't
I know if you know that chip Roy is an
insurrectionist by many following the
events at the capital we should not
continue to perpetrate claims of
insurrections at the capital and we
should not abuse the term now uh and
this is a quote by Roy because this is
from his press office account funny part
is is M the petty Yeti the house squanch
she
responded uh and that's what the Uproar
is about that's why the the weener of
the house was asked about this this
morning and his press conference but
margorie Taylor green said here you
voted to kick me out of the freedom
caucus oh boy I tell you what there's a
lot there's a lot going on here she's
really pissed off at chip Roy and Chip
Roy hates this [__]
idiot even as even as much of a scumbag
and a dumb [__] that chip Roy is he even
knows that this piece of [__] margorie
Taylor green is not good for their party
even he knows it wow that's wild
I mean he voted to kick her out of the
freedom caucus you remember that because
I think this was the whole um her and
Lauren bobbert she called Lauren bobbert
a little [__] but listen to this it
gets good but keep but keep CNN wannabe
Ken Buck who who is no longer gonna run
for his seat in Congress because of [__]
like this right Ken Buck's like [__] you
I'm out you [__] people are crazy I'm
not I'm not going to do the crazy
anymore
but the next part oh is so [__]
delicious and vaping groping Lauren
bobert this is [__] real this is not
AI I did not make this image up this is
not a produced image this is a real
[__] tweet this is
real is
it or is
it nope it's real 100% I wish I could
say that it's fake I wish I could say
that because at first I had to go verify
this I was like surely this isn't real
because I seen it as a screenshot I'm
like I gotta go see this [__]
nope it's real it's right there she
wrote this [__] on her official account
on her rep account this isn't her
personal account this is her official
Congressional account and she calls
herself a Christian on it Christian
mother American business owner and
congresswoman representing Georgia's
14th District 2.8 million bot
followers is what she's got but she's a
Christian and she calls Lauren bober a
vaping grouping Lauren
bobert I'm all here for it folks I'm not
gonna take the shovel out of their hand
she also goes on to tell Chip Roy and
she says a lot of ANS in this thing I'm
not gonna lie and you voted with the
Democrats to protect terus
Talib you hate
Trump certifi Biden's election and could
care less about January 6th defendants
being prosecuted persecuted she clearly
does not understand what he's trying to
tell her he's like hey dummy when you
call the pro peaceful protest and
Insurrection because you don't like that
they call the January 6 Insurrection
Insurrection you're admitting that the
January 6 Insurrection is an
Insurrection it's real weird
stuff totally weird weird but you know
that's how it goes and this
morning um well let me wait a second I
got to respond to this tweet because
this is a beautiful tweet but it sucks
so this tweet sucks this is what I do I
want to show you guys this so like when
she tweets this and I show it on the
show I go down and I I tell her it's
sucks and then I tell her it's featured
on the
show and I do it when it's a good tweet
too like when someone's showing a clip
and I play the clip I give them credit
for it I try to give people credit it I
just want to show you guys I don't know
if you guys some of you guys know that
because some of you guys go like those
comments on Twitter but I want to show
you that um here's here's what I said uh
to this this tweet and then I'll show
you what the the wiener of the house
said I said don't put down the shovel
please Marge don't put down the shovel
please please please don't put down the
shovel but here is um here's the the
wiener of the house this morning talking
about talking about margorie Taylor
green and Chip Roy
here is on Capitol Hill giving his his
press conference as the Wier of the
house let's listen to micro Johnson the
guy who adopted a 14-year old boy when
he was a 25y old single man that seems a
little weird but let's see if it's
getting weirder I was just uh in our
Republican conference meeting and uh
there is such a great feeling of a spree
decor amongst House Republicans we're
not only unified we are energized so
they're unified in in uh what what what
no that's not that's that's not right
you ask him about Marjorie tayor green
would you please ask him specifically
let's
see is that to mean that you've been
able to flip Thomas Massie and Mt the
last couple of days here on this in
package or you moving forward without
that I've had great discussions with um
Thomas and and margerie are close
friends and committed conservatives and
I don't disagree with them on many
issues um and principles they they
understand the necessity of us getting
our Appropriations bills done
and oh they understand they understand
so they they'll they'll create all kinds
of Chaos in the house they create all
kinds of Chaos in the house let's let's
continue with this with the wiener of
the house here because he did talk about
the Israeli funding this morning
speaking of Israeli funding and trying
to get Marjorie Taylor green and Thomas
Massie and others to get their [__]
together um of course he doesn't have
his [__] together either but let's
listen just to follow up you stress the
need to be able to pay for the Israel
funding as you know President Biden has
issued a veto threat on this bill would
you consider putting a bill on the floor
that includes funding for Israel but
does not have spending cuts or is that a
non-starter no listen we we are in Dire
Straits as a nation and if you talk to
leaders at the Joint Chiefs of Staff of
Pentagon sometimes even in recent years
under oath they've testified before the
house arm Services committee where I
served until since last week um if you
ask them what the greatest threat is to
our national security you would expect
most people expect they'd say China
Russia Iran terrorism they say it's the
national debt we have to address it we
we
have so people at deod okay this mother
do you hear what he's trying to sell you
do you hear the [__] line he's
trying to sell you the people at
DOD the armed
services the [__] military do you
have any idea how much [__] money we
spend on the military do you have any
[__]
clue holy [__] it's the biggest line
item in our goddamn bud
in this
country and this guy is claiming that
the military is concerned it's our
number one national security threat is
how much money the military gets what
the [__] because that's literally what
he's doing literally what he's going to
do is make sure that the IRS does not
have the resources monetarily with
Appropriations that that happened in the
inflation reduction act to go [__]
get money that the government is owed
this is not money that we're collecting
or we're stealing from someone it's
money they are not paying because
they're cheating on their taxes and
there's just not enough resources to go
after it and and in this effort to spend
the money to go after these [__] tax
cheats these billionaire tax cheats is
we are going to collect more money than
we're going to spend okay it's called an
investment think of it that way we're
going to invest resources to the IRS to
go collect taxes that billionaires have
cheated on and we're GNA go get that tax
dollar and it's G to cost us Pennies on
the dollar and we're talking about we're
talking about billions of dollars in
funding to the IRS to make sure they can
go collect Bill billions more in
taxes from Millions Millionaires and
billionaires who have cheated on their
taxes prior prior
taxes they not going to lock them up
there's a two-tier Justice in in this
country you try not paying your [__]
taxes you see how that works out for
you see if the IRS comes beating on your
door takes your [__] house takes your
[__] ruins your [__] life over you
know eight nine 10 12 15 $20,000 worth
of taxes oh you'd be
[__] but Millionaires and billionaires
oh [__] the government we have to spend
our money to go get our money that's
really what we're talking about here
because Millionaires and billionaires
are like yeah [__] just cheat on it
there's a whole room full of lawyers
because they can afford to pay millions
of dollars in lawyer fees to make sure
they're not spending billions of dollars
in taxes makes sense but here Mike
Johnson wants to make sure that he
extorts the Israeli
funding to protect Israel he wants to
make sure of that but let's continue
obligations and we have commitments and
we want to to protect our and help and
assist our friend uh Israel but we have
to keep our own house in order as well
and I think people at home I think the
American people understand that at home
you have to balance your budget at home
you have to you see how they talk to us
like we're [__] children don't you
hate that [__] the American PE I think
the I think the American people
understand that we understand we
understand what you're doing you're
protecting the [__]
wealthy because you became the speaker
of the house and the people that you
that now you owe your receip to all
those donors that are not going to stuff
your pockets full of money we know what
they want they want they want more
[__] money they want more of our
money if you want to know the honest
truth they want more of our money that's
going to go towards infrastructure they
want more of our money that's going to
go towards
education they want more of our
money that's going to go towards Health
Care they want more of our money that's
going to go towards National
Security there you [__] [__] but
keep going keep digging make tough
decisions and Washington should run the
same way and so we are here to change
the environment to change the Paradigm
The Way Washington thinks if we continue
on the trajectory we're on it's going to
hurt our country terribly and it's going
to hurt hardworking Americans even more
seniors and the rest so we have to while
we take care of obligations we got to do
it in a responsible manner so I I've
made this very clear to the president
myself in our in our cordial meeting
that we had I've made it very clear to
our colleag House Republicans I spoke at
their I mean Senate Republicans I spoke
at their lunch yesterday um I've to
every cabinet official I've spoken to
all the way down the line that okay this
is why I'm excited about this guy being
speaker of the house this guy's gonna
fail
miserably fail oh it's gonna be [__]
epic folks it's gonna be an epic [__]
crash
[Music]
just Mike Johnson imp ploting as he
strikes the Earth this [__]
guy all right let me break it down
another
way when Trump came to office in 2016
you remember he was saying the same [__]
oh we're gonna we're gonna run the
[__] government like like I run a
business remember that [__] Mitt Romney
said that [__] too they all these
[__] Republicans say that stupid
[__] [__] oh we're gonna run the
country like we run a business what the
[__] are you talking about what business
do you know runs like a government huh
what are you talking
about what business runs that you know
of like a government it doesn't that's
not how it works that's not how
governments work that's not how
governing Works number one that's why
this this [__] run it as a business
is always a fallacy in the first place
and then when he when he when he [__]
talks down to the American people
talking about how they're going to run
the [__] country like we run our
households hey [__] [__] you buddy
you're the you're the one you're the one
sucking at the tea corporations and
making sure labor like UAW isn't getting
the deals that they deserve from The Big
Three you [__] pieces of [__] Mike
Johnson you
[__] yeah run run the country like our
household good [__] luck with that
[__] this [__] has never
probably never felt the plight of an
average working American ever look at
him look at this son of a
[__] so don't don't even start with
that [__] but the problem is is this
same old worldview that they're going to
run the country like a business like
they did in 2016 under Trump you
remember how that worked out8 trillion
doar in four years in deficits because
folks what Mike Johnson and Republicans
are are selling is that oh we're going
to pay for the Israeli funding in
reality they're going to put it on the
credit credit card because they're
taking away money that we use to go
collect the money that we're owed from
rich
people that's right so it's going to
cost us more
money they're literally making it to
where the Israeli funding is all deficit
spending not just the [__] funding in
the first place which we could just run
up the def deficit for that spending we
can just put it on the credit card as
they say it doesn't [__] matter it's
the federal government we have the
better reserve I don't think people
really quite understand that we're not
on the gold standard anymore you dumb
sons of [__] it's not a thing and
we're not going back to it either
there's not enough [__] gold you
don't get it need to again rub a few
brain cells together do a little bit of
[__] research do your own research
not on Facebook on somewhere else that
you know makes
sense but Mike Johnson here is selling
[__] to his [__] sheep he's not
talking to us he's not talking to us
average Americans that are like wait a
second so you're going to take a money
away from the IRS that is used to go
collect taxes that that Millionaires and
billionaires try to cheat us out of and
you're saying that that's going to cost
us less money they're going to run up
more deficit and the [__] are
these sheep are so [__] blind and
they're not going to change their mind
so much that Mike Johnson just says it
outright uh here he is running away from
reporters in a hallway now this was this
was yesterday when he was being
questioned about the CBO score I don't
know if you guys know what the CBO is
it's the Congressional budget office so
what the Congressional budget office
does is anything the house does they see
how much it's going to run up the
deficit of our country the credit card
as it were that these Republicans like
to talk about they're gonna they score
to see how much credit card debt our
country is going to have and when they
scored Mike Johnson's plan to pay for
Israeli
funding
with with this IRS money it's moving the
money which means that the IRS Now does
not have this funding they're like whoa
that's going to cause they're gonna have
less money to collect more money so then
we're going to have more debt because
we're going to collect less Revenue it's
what the Internal Revenue Service does
collects Revenue but apparently Mike
Johnson does not understand that let's
listen if he even knows what the CBO is
or what they do be careful everybody be
careful were you surprised by the CBO
score sir not surprised at all only in
Washington would he cut spending do they
call it a anree in the deficit only in
Washington dud do they call it when you
reduce spending uh that it increases
deficit well when that spending is
supposed to go to collecting more
money yeah it does and this is the
[__] bone eded thinking
this is the boneheaded thinking that
they have and I'm I honestly watching
this clip again this is why I'm excited
about this guy because I actually think
this guy is so [__] dumb he's so dumb
that he's so dumb that he thinks we're
so dumb that we can't see that this guy
adopted a 14-y old boy when he was a 25y
old single man that there's something
wrong with
that he he thinks he's so dumb that he
thinks we're so dumb that we can't
understand that his wife's little
conversion therapy thing when she tried
to scrub her website of demonizing
lgbtq Q community members call calling a
bestiality and [__] that we know that
you're a [__] Nazi friend we know
you're a white Christian nationalist we
know you're a
Neo-Nazi we know what you are you piece
of [__] we're not that [__] dumb he
thinks we are but we're not but this guy
is dumb enough to believe this [__] he
just said listen be careful everybody be
careful try were you surprised by the
CBO score sir not surprised at all only
in Washington when he cut spending do
they call it a are you alarmed inre
deficit because that's not what a
deficit is a deficit is not how much how
much how much you spend or how much you
don't
spend it's how much money Revenue you
get versus how much you spend that's
where the deficit
happens this honestly if we're going to
run the [__] country like you run a
business maybe you should know how to
run a [__] business then Mike Johnson
maybe that's what the [__] you should
do I mean it didn't help that Donald
Trump and Eric Trump or Don Donald Trump
Jr went to the business school at
Wharton they don't know [__] [__]
about accounting but apparently Mike
Johnson doesn't know a goddamn thing
either that you have to have
income and then you have then you have
debts right
income and
outcome Americans who have a kitchen
table know
that they go to their [__] job and
they earn their [__] paycheck they
come home and they got to write out the
bills with the money they have incoming
the revenue that's how they make money
with the money that goes out to their
bills the money that they [__]
owe and then and then if they have a
deficit meaning they don't have enough
money to pay their [__] bills Maybe
put a few on credit cards that's their
deficit
Mike how the [__] does this guy expect
us to believe that he thinks he's going
to run the [__] country like a
business and this guy doesn't even know
Gap doesn't even know what revenue is
that that Revenue versus
Bills and he's lecturing us don't you
see how I'm excited about this guy oh my
God this guy is going to [__] crash
and burn and we're going to make sure of
it the messaging is going to be there
this guy is going to provide every
single piece of the narrative that we
need every single [__] piece of the
narrative that we need to show the
country why he should not be speaker of
the
house every single [__] last little
nugget that we need he's gonna provide
it and I know that
sucks mro
Johson I I guess rat had a a new song
there huh here let me put this one on
mute and you can you can play that one
over this here here's here's here's
small micro
[Music]
energy small eny mro
Johnson that's a catchy
tune that's a catchy tune thanks rant
thanks for the tune I'm sure the
audience is going to enjoy all these
little tunes that we've got uh
eventually we'll be able to do all kinds
of creative [__] and you won't even see
it coming so thank thank you rant thank
you and the audience appreciate
you oh my god oh I I sorry I can't I got
to do it one more time I got to do it
one more time it's it's
[Music]
good small way energy micro
Johnson
[Music]
small
way micro joh all right all right all
right that's enough that's
enough small energy micro Johnson well I
wish I wish I had a better a better way
to go to a break but I can't I can't I
can't beat that I can't beat that so
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
with more small energy from micro
Johnson and The Republic an in the
Senate the house and in courts all
around the country criminal and civil
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
right after
this what the [__] is wrong with you
people it's a rhetorical question at
[Music]
best we'll be right back on the Tony
Michaels
[Music]
podcast letters from the trucker
Convoy there's Tammy by the time we
reach DC we was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way we
got plenty of slim gems
skull near run out Natty light hope it
don't rain tomorrow so we can Circle the
city again here's Bob dear Bob I'm
fixing to send you some more of them
Doritos you like the red bag not the LI
love and blue one in your absence I
discovered a rash on my neck and no it
ain't no hickey and I even seen my
cousin bro and
ages stay strong wipe your ass at least
once a day yours
tamy [__] them [__] [__] them [__] [__]
them [__] we're back to the Tony
Michaels
podcast
welcome back to the
show thanks for sticking around through
the
break need a little sip of water there
why not end it on that note with that
great foot tapping song
about micro
Johnson little wer energy from micro
Johnson well we got we got shovel energy
from the petty Yeti here is an image of
the petty Yeti not putting down her
shovel in the house of represent and is
please M do not put down your shovel I
telling you what this AI is spot on is
it [__] this looks just like Mary Taylor
green holy [__] is this real or is this
AI
[Music]
rat I'm not going to lie this is really
[__] close ain't it I mean this is
this is almost I mean I can't even tell
the difference
really can you I think this is
real I seriously think this is
real oh wait a second wait a second it's
hard to see her feet so this this may be
AI I may be way off my rocker here we
can't see we can't see the petty Yeti's
feet so it it could be that she's got
way more this this Yeti's got more than
three toes but this is where this is
where the petty Yeti hangs out on
xgen I'm I think I'm GNA officially name
Twitter xchan here's xchan here although
this is a little this is a little too
nice to be xchan there's not enough
dumpster fires here are you sure rat are
you sure that this is that this is xgen
are we sure about this are we sure I
don't know man this xgen seems like it'd
have a lot more dumpster fires be like a
hellscape you know what I mean bunch of
Nazis running
around bunch of anti-semites everywhere
in your comments all the trolls just
like zombie trolls everywhere right
kind of like um you know Halloween just
happened so it'd be like you know
Thriller the Michael Jackson you know
musical you know what I mean just the
zombies roaming the streets I don't know
I don't know I I don't think this one's
real rant I think I think you're getting
your images mixed up here what do you
think do you think this is real rat do
you think this
is I don't
know I don't know oh well okay all right
all right all right all right maybe
maybe I'm wrong Maybe I'm Wrong all
right well go back go back in the lab
and see if you can find um an image to
back it up if this is X
xchan oh boy let's see if we got any
more images from the courtroom uh there
actually you know what you know what
just in just in there is an image that I
have of George Santos George Santos uh
is being welcome back to Ala
Representatives here's George
Santos oh my God look at this image you
know this is real when he's got the the
little fleece vest underneath his suit
jacket and then look at all the the
Republican Pirates here look at all
these fascist Pirates excited that
George Santos the
thief the indicted criminal is back in
the house that's right they made this
big theatric big
theatrics about George Sor or George
Santos excuse me say George Soros yeah
whatever George Santos being expelled
the Republicans brought the motion to
the floor and they didn't get it yeah
that's right they couldn't they couldn't
get rid of the the number one Hall of
Fame liar in the house which makes him
you know really honestly makes him
primed to be the the leader of the house
here here is um Chris Webb has it here
uh here's the uh here's the actual
vote for
it so nay was
214 couldn't even [__] couldn't even
get a simple majority now you need twoth
thirds vote in the house is what you
need two-thirds vote in the house to
expel a member of Congress it's not just
a simple majority but they couldn't even
get a simple majority
here to expel him holy H
[__] holy [__] and really honestly the
Democrats didn't make it easy on them
which they shouldn't they shouldn't the
Democrats shouldn't [__] just they
listen I've been telling you this since
the we found out who or we didn't know
who George Santos was or Anthony
devolder or whatever the hell his name
is her name is I don't
know when we found out who we didn't
know who George Santos was I said he
shouldn't resign and we shouldn't want
him to resign we should want Republicans
to have to live with him and they are
George Santos I think even gave a I
think he even gave an
interview um they couldn't even get rid
of him but he gave an interview let me
see if I can I can find it here yeah so
this is
um here is Santos running away from
reporters in the hallway as he's
responding uh to the expulsion
vote building is unacceptable oh wait
this is that's a different one that's a
different one he's bitching about
something else that's
a oh let's see here it is here it is
here's here's a little bit of George
Santos he's always in the hallways
running away from people On's
watching Mr Santos do you intend to
serve both years your term you to vote
for speaker you tell us if you plan to
serve both years of your ter oh well
that's that's that's him bullshitting
too
oh is there is there is there one that
we can watch that is George Santos
um well let's see if we can find I
listened to him say it this morning I'm
just trying to find the one of him
walking in the hallway being questioned
by reporters actually you know what
here's a good one here's Daniel Goldman
um absolutely slamming Republicans for
for George Santos watch that
recognized one of my colleagues says we
will hold members accountable you are
the party of George
Santos who are you holding accountable
the guy is an alleged and acknowledged
liar and indicted and you protect him
every day Don't lecture us with your
projection and your defense of Donald
Trump it's pathetic and it's beneath you
and it's beneath this body and I yield
back recognized one of my colleague said
there's and there's Daniel Goldman and
and
again I you know George Santos is the
shovel
that D is the shovel that the
Republicans are holding here's actually
a a clip here of George Santos yielding
the floor to Goldman as he held the
house forward watch this York Mr Santos
is recognized members are reminded to
refrain from engaging in personalities
toward the president Mr chair uh I yal
five minutes to my colleague from New
York Mr Goldman thank you very much Mr
Santos uh thank you Mr Speaker I rise
today in support of this resolution to
expel George Santos from Congress as I
did in May when I co-sponsored a similar
expulsion resolution that the sponsors
of today's resolution my colleagues from
my Republican colleagues from New York
did not
support I agree with everything that my
Republican colleagues have said here
today but everything they have said here
today was also true in May when they
voted to protect George
Santos has there been anything that has
changed nothing about the numerous lies
that Mr Santos admitted himself to
making in order to deceive his voters
into electing him nothing about his
status as an indicted criminal
defendant yes there has been a
superseding indictment with moral
allegations of criminal conduct but he
is still presumed innocent until proven
guilty as my New York
friends relied upon in May when they
voted to protect George Santos from
expulsion nothing has changed from the
Ethics Committee even though one of my
colleagues from New York said that the
Ethics Committee would expedite its
investigation and release a report 60
days from the date of that may vote
well we are now
175 days since then and there is no
ethics report that would prompt a change
of heart one thing that has changed is
that Mr Santos's campaign Treasurer pled
guilty to fraud and admitted under oath
that she conspired with Mr Santos to
fabricate a non-existent $500,000 loan
to his campaign but the resolution
drafted by my friends from New York does
not even mention that new fact so here's
the thing and a lot of people were
confused by this they're like why did
Democrats vote not to expel George
Santos
because folks because George Santos is a
Republican and they deserve
him they deserve him so I'm glad the
repu there's Democrats in the house that
didn't vote to expel him [__] [__] that
[__] F let them [__] live with him
just what Daniel Goldman said here I
can't even believe that they can't they
didn't even put the new superseding
indictment in the
resolution the one thing that has
changed since people have been calling
for him to be expelled the one thing
that has changed they didn't even put it
in the motion to expel him which means
that Republicans knew this entire time
the whole time that George Santos should
have been expelled from Congress so why
should Democrats do the [__] bidding
of Republicans why do Democrats have to
[__] elect their leaders why do
Democrats have to to expel their [__]
criminal members why do we have to do
that [__] [__] you take care of your own
do your [__] clean your [__] house
okay clean your [__] house over there
and then we can do some business
together so good I'm glad there's
[__] Democrats that voted to keep
George Santos tied around the necks of
Republicans to make them have to [__]
own that piece of lion [__] [__] them
[__] them again folks we're in it to win
it and there ain't there ain't no
winning if we don't if we don't win next
year that's right they control the
[__] house concus they picked their
guy micro
Johnson they got the petti yeti with her
shovel and her backo good keep going
keep doing
it and there ain't a goddamn thing we
can do about it this is this is why we
have to get our asses out and we have to
engage in democracy because it ain't
just this next election that matters
it's every [__] one of them matter
they all matter until we can get the
American people to really realize that
hey I know you got a busy life but you
really got to pay attention a little bit
to this stuff just a [__] little bit
and really honestly listening to your
your [__] Uncle Fred on Facebook is
not the place you need to figure out who
you're gonna vote for Jesus [__]
Christ that's what led us to this
[__] mess in the first
place pluck your head out of your ass
for a half second and that where you
engage you have to engage the
country that's what I mean by it right
we got to get these people to wake the
[__] up and realize that oh oh that's
why people keep saying don't vote for
Republicans they want to take our
[__] Liberty they want to give all
the money to a few of their [__]
donors and all the while they can't
govern it's by Design folks this [__] is
by Design do you really really believe
that Mike Johnson believes that if he
takes IRS funding that it won't add to
the deficit that's the dumbest [__] I've
ever heard of in my life if Mike Johnson
is smart enough to be the speaker of the
house then he should be smart enough to
realize that if you take funding that
he's going to take from the IRS that the
deficit is going to go up and they
always know that Republicans have always
known this [__] they always have hid
their fascism behind a thin veil of
conservatism oh we want to we we want to
be of our national debt oh really where
were you during 2016 to
2020 when Trump was in office and the
and the national deficit went eight
trillion dollar the same amount in eight
years under Obama that you guys [__]
act like it was the end of the world and
it
wasn't the eight the eight trillion
dollars worth of debt Brock Obama put on
our country wasn't the end of the world
and the reason why it wasn't is because
the8 trillion dollars that Trump put on
our de debt wasn't the end of the world
still
isn't still isn't the end of the world
or the end of the country and it's not
the number one national security threat
the one number one national security
threat that we have in our country is
domestic terrorism and we got guns just
pouring out on our [__] streets
weapons of war that's the number one
threat to Americans here in our country
you [__] boneheads not the debt the
[__] out of here what how many people
how many Mass how many mass [__]
Financial dearies have you seen huh how
many people have died because the
national debt went into an elementary
school and mow down a bunch of
children with dollar dollar bills y'all
really that's the number one threat [__]
out of here with that
[__] you can't even you can't even
muster up enough courage to support the
American working class and and and be
happy that the UAW did the deal with the
big three and got auto manufacturers
back on an even Keel with their workers
that's called a good economy that's
called a good Market is what that's
called and that's only good for everyone
in the country by the
way so give me a [__]
break when they're when when we're going
to we're going to act like it should be
the Democrats that sa the Republicans
from George Santos [__] you I want
George Santos in
court and not giving up his [__]
seat next year during the election and
the Republicans have to sit and defend
that [__] piece of
[__] [__] them let them have to defend
that son of a [__] just like they're
defending Donald
Trump and it's criminal civil
trials [__] them [__] them [__] them
[__] them it's about goddamn time that
we let them touch the [__] hot
stove for years and years and decades
and decades us the pro-democracy
Coalition in the interest of our country
and the and the
longterm ability for us to govern in
this country we have we have let them
[__] run a
muck and dive deeper and deeper and
deeper into
fascism without saying a goddamn word
and acting like acting like they're not
fascist Jesus Christ people run around
acting like Liz Cheney is a goddamn hero
I will NE listen to me listen to me very
carefully I will never ever ever ever
ever call Liz channy an American hero
ever won't [__]
happen that [__] scumbag wants to
take Healthcare rights away from
women she believed that the
Democrats want to make it to where women
could kill their babies after they're
born stupid [__] like that using using
lies and cudel like that to take away
women's right to
healthare that alone just that one point
is enough for me to never consider her
ever an American hero she did the bare
[__] minimum and frankly she didn't
even do the bare [__]
minimum she didn't she didn't do the
bare minimum she weighed 190 days go do
the count I counted it 190 days it took
her to go to the floor and to put in an
official record that Donald Trump had
lost
days mark it down go tell everyone on
Facebook or on Twitter xchan on threads
whatever social media your site you're
on because it's
true Shan no [__]
hero sh a't no better than George
Santos [__] that [__] you think Kevin
McCarthy or Mike Johnson margorie Taylor
green Lauren bobert Matt gats chip
Roy Paul
goar these [__]
scumbags you think that you think
they're any different than George Santos
they're [__] lying sex as [__] they
aren't who they say they are Mike
Johnson claims to be this great
Christian person he was he was weirdly
when he was 25 and a single man he was
adopting 14-year-old boys
folks what in the [__] does a
25-year-old single man want to adopt a
14-year-old adopt because he didn't
officially adopt
him weird
stuff somehow that's
Christian come on
man somehow because Liz Cheney did the
bear minimum and she joined the January
6 select committee and was willing to
say the truth out loud oh oh well [__]
me she's will to say the truth out loud
we make her an American hero then [__]
that
[__] her and Adam kininger too I showed
you a clip the other day of Adam
kininger saying I'm not gonna not call
myself a republican even though I vote
for Democrats even though I don't
believe in the Republican Party even
though the Republican party is dead get
the [__] out of
here it's a sickness that we have in
this country it's an affiliation
sickness and you know what you know what
[__] them if they want to willingly have
the disease and walk around being
[__] just fascist zombies fine
fine let's at least be able to [__]
point them out to
everybody and show the [__] country
why you should be paying attention and
why you should pluck your head out of
your ass and understand that there are
people in this country who who are for
democracy and there are Republicans who
are for
autocracy that's your choices and I know
it's it's a bleak choice and tyt
Watchers are going to get all upset well
we should have more
choices we should have more choices
Tony what the [__] are you talking about
more choices on
what why in the [__] do we need to more
choices than autocracy or democracy it's
a pretty easy one pretty [__] easy
one a pick I don't know about
you so let them have George
Santos let them be held accountable for
having George
Santos good for them they deserve him
every [__] day of the week just like
they deserve Tommy tuberville same
[__] thing same [__] same
[__] [__] they deserve that son of a
[__]
they made this [__] bed they should
sleep in it Tommy tuberville even
Lindsey Grahams pissed off at him here
here's a little here's a little clip
from the Senate because Tommy tuberville
held up all almost 400 promotions and
DOD which is standard oper raising
Senate procedure where the dod presents
their promotions and the Senate votes on
them as a blanket trusting the dod with
their promotions but Tommy tuberville
doesn't want women in the military
because that's what he's
saying that's really what he's
saying Tommy tville has been holding up
military promotions blocking them in the
Senate because he doesn't want he
doesn't want a woman to drive across the
state line to receive medical attention
he she doesn't want her going to the
doctor Tommy to reveal just doesn't like
when them women folk go to the doctor
and frankly if that means they shouldn't
be in the military then Tommy tuberville
probably thinks that's a good thing
too it's truly what they want that's
what they mean when the military's woke
they mean women's in the military that's
what it
means it's what it means to the toxic
the toxic masculinity masquerading out
there these [__] fake ass incels
thinking they're tough guys like Tommy
tuberville here even Lindsey Graham even
lady G knows he's not a tough guy listen
to this it's about keeping politics
politics out of the military I did not
put it in the military Joe Biden and
secretary Austin put politics in
Military and it's about the right to
life so which is it is it about politics
or is it about you don't want women in
the military because it feels like to me
that I don't know everything's about
politics when it I don't
know comes to the floor of a political
body like the Senate of course it's
[__] po how the [__] what in the [__]
don't how God damn
it it's politics folks it's on the floor
of the
Senate we elect these people as
politicians to represent us in our
Republic Jesus [__] Christ to go make
decisions as
politicians using
politics God
damn it's exhausting that that the Sheep
don't know this these is some of the
most important things in the world to
me and so Mr President I object
objection is heard Mr President from
South Carolina yeah I'll have another
one uh let me respond to my C colleague
respectfully we have cour actually uh
lady G you should do it not respectfully
you should really I mean honestly this
respect thing is not getting us very far
when you're doing this [__] where you're
you're being respect respectful to Tommy
tville see that that's the kind of
discourse that I think that we should
rebut enough of that [__] enough of
[__] playing playing Koy with Tommy
Tu enough of giving him what he [__]
wants [__] that guy [__] him and [__]
any scumbag that's that's funding him
because someone is paying someone is
paying Tommy tuberville to do this Tommy
tuberville would not have the Intuition
or or The Willpower to continue this
[__] if there wasn't money behind
it no way neither would Republicans cuz
watch lady G here watch him watch her
him what whatever we have
courts if you think they've done
something illegal go to court that's how
you handle these things the Pentagon has
issued a legal opinion I disagree with
saying this doesn't violate the height
amendment I just dis agree with it
here's what's going to happen you've
just denied this lady a promotion you
did
that all of us are ready to promote her
because she deserves to be promoted she
had nothing to do with this policy let
me say it again everybody in this body
could find an issue with any
Administration they don't agree with and
what we're going to do is open up
Pandora's Box today is abortion policy
if we take back the White House we'll go
back to the Mexico City policy limiting
dollars to be given to overseas entities
that are engaged in the abortion
business some pro-choice people don't
like that what would happen if they put
a hold on all the officers because they
don't agree with the Republican
Administration there's a reason this
this has not been done this way for a
couple hundred years no matter where you
believe it or not Caville this is doing
great damage to our military I don't say
that lightly I've been trying to work
with you for nine months okay so lindsy
Graham obviously he understands it but
he didn't get to the point let me show
you the point here uh where he gets to
right about actually you know what I
want to show you something else here I
know this seems a
little this seems a little petty but if
you look in the background here is that
is that Kirsten Cinema walking in the
background can someone confirm that for
me I'm just saying I can't see anything
but her skirt and her boots but I think
that's Kirsten Cinema in the background
there probably okay so here's the point
where Lindsey Graham he makes the point
but he doesn't get
it which is is not surprising it's not
surprising that they don't [__] get
it the the point is the reason why Tommy
T Ral is stopping this nomination isn't
because of abortion it isn't because of
a wokeness it isn't because of Joe Joe
Joe Biden Joe Biden it's not because of
that let me give you a little [__]
hint Lindsey Graham says it out loud let
me give you a little hint he says it out
loud here
listen I disagree with it here's what's
going to happen you've just denied this
lady a promotion you did
that you just denied this lady a
promotion you did that it ain't got
nothing to do with abortion it ain't got
[__] nothing to do with
wokeness Tommy tuberville's goal is to
make
sure that there are not women in the
military I told you that months ago when
he was doing
this months ago because the thinking is
well here's the deal here's the deal
Tommy Tommy says well here's the deal I
tell you what we just don't have women
in the military and then we don't have
to do any of this stuff about abortion
we have to do anything about
abortion because here's the thing here
thing there're no women in military we
don't have to give them hell care at all
see see that's what we don't have to do
we don't have to give women anything in
this country they shouldn't have the
right to vote they shouldn't have the
right to travel and and and lovec Texas
or Texas in general they shouldn't be
able to go to the doctor's pointless me
me tuberville says that you can go to
the [__] doctor the way that I want
you to go to the doctor I mean if I get
you pregnant if me Tomic tuberville get
you pregnant then I want you to go to
the doctor get an abortion but if you're
going to go get an abortion for someone
else other than Tommy tuberville I don't
want you to have it okay you see I don't
want women in the
military that's what the [__] it's been
about the whole godamn time the whole
whole goddamn time when any [__] some
misogynic piece of [__] some Macho Man
oh yeah Macho Man when any macho man who
hasn't been in the military like Tommy
duville is talking to you about how the
military's less
manly he's not saying it that way but
it's less manly he [__] means that he
does not want women in the military
that's what he means by
wokeness listen to it a [__] again
listen to it here's [__] Lindsey
Graham
listen to what she says again lady G
will tell you he does she didn't get it
he does get it whatever but he says it
out loud listen saying this doesn't
violate the H amendment I disagree with
it here's what's going to happen you've
just denied this lady a promotion you
did
that all of us are ready to promote her
because she deserves to be promoted she
had nothing to do with this
policy there you go she had nothing to
do with this
policy nothing to do with this policy
but she's got a giner she's got one of
them lady Parts they're always focused
oh God they're [__] hyperfocused on
what gender and who's what and what's a
woman what's a
woman she's
qualified to be in this
position
DOD has said she's qualified the Senate
overwhelmingly
wants to individually promote her which
they do not do normally normally it's a
blanket promotion they do all these
promotions with one vote because they
trust DOD to make these promotions
inside their military
ranks Tommy tuberville and I've said it
for months and months and months that
this is not about abortion this is not
about wokeness in the military they do
not want women
in the military and if we could find I
almost bet if you could find a big
funding apparatus out there in the right
wing that is hyperfocused on women not
being in the military and really
honestly you could probably start at
Women's Health Care like them taking
away Women's Health Care roie Wade
absolutely stripping roie Wade and also
paired with women not taking away the
rights of women to vote I almost bet
you'd find exactly who the [__] is
paying Tommy a to do
this I almost bet b Bottom Dollar you
could find exactly who the [__] is
funding Tommy tuberville to do this who
is pushing him to do
this same [__] people who use
abortion as a cudel the same [__]
people who convince their [__] sheep
that abortion is the only issue you vote
on the same [__] people who who
convince white fragile men that there's
no such thing as privilege and that this
isn't a democracy it's a republic same
[__] same
[__] and here Lindsey Graham is
walking smack dab into why Tommy
tuberville does not want to do this why
he doesn't want this
woman to be promoted in the military and
he's he still can't get the [__] out of
his brains to realize what's going on
because if he did he'd call it out right
there on the senate floor
uh Tony Phillips makes a pretty good
point probably harlon
Hitler could
be could be harlon
Hitler that's paying Tommy tuberville to
do this I don't know how many times
Tommy tuberville has went down and sat
and had a reading out of the signed copy
of mine comp with harlon Hitler but I'm
sure it's been more than
once what a [__] scumbag Tommy
tuberville is
and it ain't just about our national
security folks you sh I mean you should
be really pissed off especially if
you're a veteran if you've served this
[__] country or if you have family
members that have served this country or
if you've lost family members that have
served this [__] country for Tommy
tuberville some [__] Podunk goddamn
Florida man who is a senator in Alabama
he's a goddamn carpet
bagger is standing in the way of the do
DOD promoting our national security
apparatus to their post to make sure
that our national security isn't at
risk you should be [__]
livid about
that but the fact that all this is about
that Tommy tuberville wants to create
the narrative because that's what
they're doing
[__] that's what they're doing
they're planting the seeds of
narrative that's what Tommy tuberville
is doing that's what probably Haron
Hitler is funding here I bet those
[__] scumbags those Nazi scumbags
have been down in Texas in his goddamn
Hitler Library sitting
around drinking conac [__] reading
from the sign copy of
minec talking about how oh they can get
the narrative going in this country they
can get the real the internet white
incel Bros to really spark up the
narrative that women shouldn't be in the
military that would solve Tommy
tuberville's
problem what do you think this
is it's an attack on women
folks and it's just not the attack on
women about their health care
rights it's not just about that that's
what they want it to appear to
be they want you to think that it's
about
abortion and it's about [__]
handmaid's tail type
[__] the same [__] that they do with
trans kids in this
country same [__] [__] they use them
as a cudgel as a national narrative to
take away parental consent away from
children that's right it ain't just
going to stop at trans kids taking away
parental consent they're coming after
your [__] consent too they'll do
it and they do it by shaping
narratives enforcing [__] politicians
like Republicans who are soulless
soulless
Pricks that have their [__] grasp on
our
governments our governments it's ours we
the people we are the [__]
government
it's to create the
narrative because they know if they can
create enough of a narrative to scare
these politicians into thinking that
they won't get reelected unless they
start saying [__] like women shouldn't
be in the [__] military where do you
think it ends they don't want women to
have the right to Health Care they don't
want women to have the right to [__]
drive to a Goddamn doctor's appointment
now they they're not going to want women
in the military they're not going to
want women in certain jobs they're not
going to want women to
vote what do you think this
is how do you think fascism
works it ain't about abortion he's so
[__] full of
[__] and when we when we fight this on
the ground of abortion we
lose because their win isn't rather
Tommy tuberville stops these
nominations harlon Hitler if he is the
funer of this he doesn't give a [__] if
the Senate finally passes these
promotions he doesn't give a
[__] what he cares about is that the
national The Narrative
sticks that women shouldn't be in the
military see let me show you an example
let me show you Shaz the general of the
shart Army here he is here he is folks
here he [__] is why are women in our
military we must revisit our core
American
values see hey Shaz I hate to I hate to
disappoint you friend but the core
American values that you're referring to
you wouldn't last five [__] minutes
my
friend they'd string you up buddy
because they they would know who you are
they'd smoke you out oh my God that
closet would open up you'd be so [__]
you have no idea the the cute thing is
though Shad the cute thing is is the
fascist have convinced you that that
you're one of
them because you get all butt hurt
online about women so you hate on women
and you hate on the gay community you
[__]
bigot and and they've made you think
they've made you think they've duped you
into believing that all you got to do is
be bigoted and you'll be one of
them that ain't where fascism stops
buddy cuz I'm your right to be a bigoted
little piece of [__] in my comments I
don't know if anyone knows this I
haven't I haven't booted chz he hasn't
said he hasn't said enough vile [__] for
me to boot him yet as soon as he does
you know I'll open his [__] I'll open
the door for him with his head and he'll
be
exited
promptly but as far as I'm concerned
Shaz
here still has
hope if he's not a bot
that's
right one day maybe Shaz will wake up
and realize he's been lied to by the
fascist that they the fascist want to
make sure Shez helps them take the
rights away from other people and
oppress other people's rights that way
one day there's no one there to protect
them when they come after
Shez that's the [__]
truth that's what all this [__] about
Tommy tuber about it ain't about no
[__] abortion it ain't about no
crossing state lines or federal funding
they don't give a [__] about that Chaz
they don't give a [__] about
that they want to make women second
class citizens so they can make people
like you second class citizens you dumb
son of a
[__] and you don't even know it that's
the [__] weird part is that you come
here every day listen to this [__] and
you still ain't got nothing brain cells
to rub together to
realize that you pushing to oppress the
rights of other people only only gives
the fascist ability to oppress your
rights this machine kills
fascist the microphone the speech but
you got to aim it in a certain way and
we do hear on the Tony Michaels
podcast and this audience
engages like crazy it
engages every single day Monday through
Friday two full [__] hours here on
YouTube twitch and
Facebook and I promise you I promise you
that I will never ever ever not point
out what someone what a scumbag like
Tommy tuberville is trying to do to our
country and I'm not just talking about
this the lies that he tells about
abortion I'm talking about his overall
goal his goal is to plant the seeds of
narrative in in dumb [__] like shaz's
mind to convince them that women are
second class citizens because they
believe the fascists believe if they can
convince enough people of
that then they can get them to commit
atrocities you just [__] hide and
watch or come here every single weekday
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific on YouTube twitch and
Facebook Gabe Sanchez does not have a
show today I know some people are asking
Gabe Sanchez does not have a show today
apparently he's having technical
difficulties um so I don't know if he'll
have a show later on so pay attention to
gab's channel but he's we're not going
to be throwing to Gabe today because he
doesn't have anything to throw to
because he has techn teal difficulties
but you should stay in the fight of
fascism just like I'm going to every
single weekday visit the tony.com go get
you some this machine kills fascist
merch the Tony Michaels podcast official
tattoo merch collection that's right I'm
going to get this design an inspiration
of this design on my arm tattooed in
January so go get your tattoo merch now
and by the way if you order tattoo merch
or the even my dog hates Ted Cruz merch
the even my dog hat take merch it is on
its way that's right the first orders
have been shipped and you guys can wear
it when you come to your first book club
meeting that's right we got a book club
with the [__] them fam now go to the
Tony michaels.com pan on down you can
click the book club link it'll take you
straight to Discord where the book club
their first book They're going to read
is the obstacle is the way by Ryan
holiday they're also going to be
listening to the audio version of Rachel
mat's book and having discussions live
in Discord I know if you don't like
Discord uh you may not want to do the
other Discord stuff but I'm telling you
you really you really should go to the
Tony michaels.com and you should you
should go to the book the book club uh
pan all the way down to memberships the
book club is right here check out the
book club it's going to be wonderful um
there's going to be audio uh discussions
so you're not even some of these books
you're not even have to buy and you're
not gonna have to buy to be part of the
book club and have the discussion at
least hear what the book's about and
what people think about it um and
there's some opportunities to get like a
free trial and actually read some of
these books for free it won't cost you a
single thing and it doesn't cost you a
single thing to be a member of the book
club so get in on it I appreciate every
single one of you as I do I appreciate
the mods I appreciate everyone who
contributes to this show and I even
appreciate Shaz that's right Shaz man
the more you show up the more I have
hope for you really honestly I think he
is I I think there's hope for Shaz in
the Shar Army still I'm not going to
give up hope on them they're Americans
just like we are well I mean they need a
few more brain cells to rub together
maybe will give it to them every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific until
tomorrow same time same
place surf up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events in
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow toning
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after
me [__] them [__]
[Music]
them Murphy's muor head ass
speaking small wer energy micro
Johnson
small wer energy mro
[Music]
Johnson small wer energy micro
Johnson small way
energy micro
[Music]
Johnson small way energy micro
Johnson